Consider the eighth root of a when it would be a
surd In the previous video we saw that a
surd is an irrational root of a positive rational
number It means a should be a positive rational
number and the result should be
irrational Some examples of a surd  R cube
root 5 and root 12 There are a few conditions we need to keep
in mind The first condition says that this is a
given if n is a natural
number greater than 1 The order of the index has to be
greater than 1 here  We can see the
order is th and square root
means the order is to the second condition says that a has to be
positive rational numbers 5 and 12 are
positive and rational and the result of th root
of a should be
irrational if we calculate the values  Of those
two numbers we will see that they are non
terminating and non recurring which makes them
irrational so these are the three important
conditions that make the number a number what about the
sixth root of na is it a number well the
order is a natural  Number Greater Than One The
Base Is A Positive Rational Number And The Result Will
Be An Irrational Number That Makes It A
Surd What About The Fourth Root Of 16 The Order
Is A Natural Number Greater Than One The Base Is A
Positive Rational Number But Wait Is  The Result
Irrational Know It Equals Two Since The Third
Condition Is Not Satisfied This Is Not As Surd There Is Another
Important Thing We Need To Know About
Surds Surds With Order Equal Too Are Given A
Special Name They Are Called
Quadratic Surds
Now We Come To The  Last and the most
interesting concept in this video
consider the number cube root of square root 5 is
this a circle let's think of the conditions the
order has to be a natural number greater than one this
condition is satisfied but what is the
base here its square root  5 The
Base Is
Irrational Let's Go Back and See the Conditions The
second condition says that the base has to be a
positive rational number but in the example we can say
The Base is
Irrational so does this mean that this is not a
number Let's see  No that the eighth root of a can be
written in exponential form as a ray
1 ba n this is the power of the exponent and
this is the base the exponent becomes the recipe procl
of the order so the cube root of √5
Can be written as √5 dal re
1/3 This is the base and 1/3 is the
export Can we also write the base in
original form Yes it can be written as
5 Re 1/2 and the whole thing is rate
1  /3 Wait a moment to see what we're getting at when you happen to
remember the power law The
power law says that a re m dal re n e a re
m m n If we apply it here this will equal
5 re
1/  6 If you look at it close it is in the a
re 1 ba n form using this formula we can write it as
6 ret 5 yr the order is a
natural number greater than w and the base f is a
positive rational number so this is  What Makes This
A Surd Too After We
Modify This A Bit We Release That It Is
Indeed A Surd We Will Understand This Part
Video In Much More Detail In The Coming
[Music]
Videos